natalia vino desde jarc y en el noroeste
de ucrania para llegar hasta este centro
de refugiados en polonia tuvo que tomar
cuatro trenes fueron dos días de viaje
extenuante para ella su suegra y su
madre
llevaba más de un mes sin poder dormir
bien en mi casa
cosa
porque se puede dormir sólo un poco
tal vez una hora o dos
cuando todo está tranquilo
que no sleep pero después ya no por las
bombas
es muy peligroso
[Música]
desmadre anoche los remos
casi 6 o 7 horas
es
ahora me siento segura aquí
natalia tardó más de un mes en convencer
a su madre ya su suegra de que
abandonaran el país
ellas no querían irse dejar que el
marido de natalia se quedo
con su carro transporta personas y
medicamentos a través de una ciudad
bombardeada sin tregua
destruyeron el centro de la ciudad que
era hermoso
había casas del siglo 19 que resistieron
a la primera y a la segunda guerra
mundial
y ahora en el siglo 21 fueron destruidas
terribles
natalia nació en la unión soviética su
madre es ucraniana su padre ruso nunca
se habrían imaginado que los rusos
atacarían jarquín
y nuestra ciudad siempre fue leal con
los rusos
nunca fue un problema habla ruso porque
jarquín es una ciudad donde se habla
ruso
todos tenemos relaciones con los rusos
sobre lesiones
cuando su madre reciba la visa se
dirigirán hacia inglaterra donde las
esperan unos amigos
la mayoría de las personas se quedan en
este centro dos o tres días hay 450
camas disponibles
los refugiados pueden encontrar
productos de higiene duchas ropa y una
lavandería
cada refugiado y cada voluntario llevan
puesto un brazalete
es por seguridad
aquí sólo hay refugiados ucranianos
voluntarios y miembros en nuestra abuela
no queremos que cualquiera puede venir
aquí podría ser peligroso para los
refugiados
un médico y una enfermera trabajan aquí
para atenderlos están disponibles 24/7
el doctor es serio a se ofreció como
voluntario nuclean es un país que conoce
bien porque estudió medicina ahí durante
seis años
algunas de las enfermedades más
recurrentes son la hipertensión y los
problemas de ansiedad las personas están
muy ansiosas a causa del estrés y de los
traumas que han vivido durante las
últimas semanas
una decena de voluntarios viene aquí
todos los días para tratar de ayudar y
reconfortar a estos refugiados la
mayoría llegan perdidos y desorientados
y huila es ucraniana salió de kiev el 28
de febrero desde entonces trabaja como
voluntaria en este centro
[Música]
conozco la situación en ucrania sé lo
difícil que puede ser
no importa si destruyeron tu casa lo de
alguien más
es algo que duele muchísimo
entonces cuando veo a las personas
sonreír después de haber llorado pienso
que hice un buen trabajo
nuestro pueblo es muy valiente no tiene
miedo yo también quiero volver pero no
cuando acabe la guerra estoy pensando en
volver ahora
marina también espera poder regresar
algún día a ucrania
entretanto viajará a berlín con sus dos
hijas y tomó más de 48 horas llegar
hasta polonia desde esa orilla
la situación en nuestro país en nuestra
región no es tranquila territorio que
hay territorios ocupados o incluso
ciudades pequeñas
y ahí hay un problema humanitario
no tanto
donde su ex
estamos muy agradecidos con polonia son
muy generosos y realmente nos ayudan
mucho
tienen un corazón muy grande
polonia es el país europeo que más
refugiados ha recibido desde el comienzo
de la guerra en ucrania casi 3 millones
de personas de las cuales la gran
mayoría son mujeres y niños